partout. Là, Tadoussac, vous
allez le voir dans le reportage
très intéressant, ne veut pas
revivre les débordements de l'an
dernier. Valérie Gamache.
- Fait qu'on va rentrer par ici,
la grande porte.
- Marilène et Isaria ont pris
la clé des champs dans
ce minibus complètement modifié.
ISARIA JOLY,
étudiante en travail social
- On a une table avec deux
banquettes pour qu'on s'asseoit.
Puis notre lit dans le fond
avec des étagères pour mettre
notre linge.
- Un lavabo à pompe, à pompe
à eau, puis on a une glacière.
On n'a pas de frigidaire, on a
une glacière avec de la glace.
Puis un petit poêlon aussi.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une première escapade routière
pour ces deux étudiantes
en travail social.
- On est parties de La Tuque,
on a fait au niveau du Saguenay,
Chicoutimi. On est allées
voir un peu des radonnées.
Là on s'est rendues à Tadoussac.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un itinéraire que bien
des Québécois vont emprunter
cet été.
MARTIN OUELLET, député, PQ
René-Lévesque, Québec
- Quand on parle aux gens
avec l'été qu'on a connu,
ceux et celles qui ont fait
le tour de la Gaspésie se sont
donné rendez-vous cette année
pour le tour de la Côte-Nord.
- Tadoussac est la première
carte postale qu'offre
la Côte-Nord. Un village
essentiellement touristique;
à preuve on y dénombre
800 habitants, mais les
infrastrucutres municipales
peuvent accueillir jusqu'à
8000 personnes.
CHARLES BRETON, maire, Tadoussac
- L'été, on est surpris quand
on voit quelqu'un qu'on connaît,
pis l'hiver, on est surpris
quand on voit quelqu'un
qu'on connaît pas.
- Le village affiche déjà
presque complet. Si bien que
la municipalité se prépare
à des débordements.
Ce terrain a été défriché
pour y aménager un nouveau
stationnement.
- Cet apprentissage-là est fait
un peu partout. Les gens
prévoient... les municipalités
prévoient des campings de...
en cas de débordement, là.
Surtout les VR, pour un
dépannage peut-être une nuit.
On veut pas créer un camping
ni l'habitude des gens de dire :
"On part puis on verra bien".
- Et on ne veut pas non plus
que les touristes abiment
les milieux naturels.
- Les gens imaginent que parce
qu'il y a une grande nature
qu'on peut tout faire, mais non.
- Sur les dunes de Tadoussac,
les messages d'interdiction d'y
passer la nuit ne suffisent pas.
- Si on surveille 24 heures
sur 24, c'est très coûteux.
Ça peut être dans les 100 000,
120 000 $. Dans certains
endroits, il faut presque le
faire parce que dès qu'on tourne
le dos, bien ça s'installe.
- La microbrasserie Tadoussac se
prépare également à recevoir
beaucoup de visite.
JÉRÉMIE PERREAULT, chef d'équipe
Microbrasserie Tadoussac
- On espère pour le meilleur
fait qu'on se prépare pour
le meilleur. On espère avoir
un été aussi... aussi mouvementé
que le dernier. On a fini
par manquer de bière, à la fin
de l'été. Je vous dirais,
on est victimes un peu
de notre popularité.
- Mais il n'y a pas que la bière
qui risque de manquer.
- L'autre grande question,
c'est : est-ce qu'on aura
la capacité, les travailleurs
et travailleuses, pour donner
le service dans les restaurants,
dans les différentes boutiques.
C'est la grande question
que Tadousac doit se poser.
- La microbrasserie double
ses effectifs pendant l'été.
Mais le défi cette année,
c'est de recruter des employés
malgré une saison plus courte.
- Habituellement, mettons
qu'on a des employés qui
viennent pour 3-4 mois,
là mettons, ça va être juste
2 mois et demi à la place.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Encore cette année,
la saison touristique va encore
se limiter aux quelques semaines
des vacances des Québécois.
Un coup dur pour l'industrie
de l'observation des baleines.
Chez croisières AML, plusieurs
embarcations resteront
dans les hangars.
- On a 65 % de extra Québec.
- Sans les touristes étrangers,
qui arrivent généralement en mai
et qui voyagent jusqu'à la fin
octobre, l'entreprise navigue
en eaux troubles.
LOÏC HAMEL, vice-président
exploitation, Croisières AML
- Les trésories y ont passé.
C'est quand même quelque chose
d'incroyable de réduire
son chiffre d'affaires de 75 %.
- La saison d'observation
des baleines commencera autour
du 24 juin, trop tard pour que
Marilène et Isaria puissent
en profiter.
(démarrage du moteur)
Les deux étudiantes s'apprêtent
à rentrer à la maison la tête
pleine de souvenirs.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Tadoussac.